Let me actually now start giving
you more details about what coded
photography could mean.
Here, I'm basically just
showing you a single image,
one photograph of basically some
bottles, some cans, and a pack of chips.
If I just take this one picture, what
I'd like to be able to get out of this
is basically some sort of a depth map.
Now, we've looked at how
to compute depth, and
we've talked about how to compute depth
by taking two images, a stereo pair.
And we can compute something like this.
Imagine in one image,
we can actually now decode it,
to be able to get information that gives
you depth in some detail like this.
Another example we can play with
is where just the same single
input image can allow us to now
compute a all-focused image.
Everything in this, er, all layers of
this image are now completely focused.
Here you can see a little bit
of blurriness in this image,
because of defocusing.
Or you know,
some of this is also defocused.
But here each and every part when
you cans see there are multiple
layers of this one all are focused.
You can basically look at a little bit
of close ups, see what I mean by this.
More detail,
more crispness at all levels here,
this one is of course defocused.